all right I got I got sound
this show is brought to you by score big
the next time you want to go see any
show or sporting event go to score big
first
go to score big and enter promo code
Joey at checkout and you'll save an
extra 20 off of your first ticket
purchase
and go check out the score big app for
your iPhone
scorebig.com and use promo code Joey to
get the 20 off of your first order and
the show is brought to you by headspace
go to headspace.com Joey and download
the free headspace app and begin their
take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation
that's headspace.com Joey and the show
is brought to you by anna.com go to
onnit.com and use code word church to
save 10 on all of their optimization
products that's on in codeword Church
[Music]
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with
Wednesday night May 4th set the Mexicans
free talks up cause it's all over Cinco
the [__] Mayo Andrew Dice Clay
Eleanor Kerrigan and my main man the
flying Jew and little brother Lee Siam
I don't know what the [__] you're doing
but whatever you're doing it's over
[Music]
oh [__] Seven Stars deep tonight mainly
750 milligrams out of respect for Andrew
Dice Clay you might even open up another
one Lisa yet
we might have to what's happening I'm
already having a great time this is
[__] phenomenal this is nice and
relaxed this is like the greatest thing
I've ever done in about 15 years it's
like it's not because but besides the
fact that when he hit that music I'm
bobbing along because I'm all [__]
stoned out already with with Joey D Joey
Coco and the flying Julie and Eleanor
Jay Kerrigan whoa I got a jet no but um
but it's this setup I like this yeah the
vibe is great this is like what I like
in my house this is like what my room
looks like with the lights that's what I
like
that's who I am the Ambiance she'll tell
you yeah everything's lava lamps and
like like you know that psychedelic kind
of feel to it it's like it's like no we
don't we need a lava lamp
Wheels always tough you got to get a
lava lamp yeah no no
uh-oh I gotta get you a lava lamp where
do you get the lava lamps nobody you
can't get them that's what's with the
questions Joey I know I just I'm always
curious no no not all about the [__]
lava lamp there's 10 of them so many in
his house
are you counting in your house there's
eight nine if you count my closet you
know because I gotta walk Lots in the
closet yeah the closet's good closet's
like a lounge in my in my bedroom you
know but Wheels puts it the best my uh
my friend Wheels which you know people
are going who's Wheels you know uh it's
one of my opening acts and uh and he's
my first best friend which I don't know
but he tells me he's weird no because
we're talking about the lavas he goes
you know it's one thing to want to bang
a lot
he goes but when you bang he goes it's
an absolute production number just in
your bedroom
like Max would talk about it like you
know because I used to know Eleanor like
in that way
and like in between Eleanor and Valerie
you don't say that it was like say what
that's a terrible thing to say in
between like well I'm not looking to
embarrass you in any way what's too
embarrassed there was like 15 girls in
between maybe more
but that that's what I'm talking about
okay yeah so Eleanor would get me these
girls that's true no no no but the
bottom but but she knows like firsthand
like the room's Gotta Have A vibe I'm
not like the type of guy that just wants
to do it's not like boring yeah it's
like an event and it's instant when it
starts getting dark different
combination of Lights goes on every
night because I can't live with a dimmed
down little dimmer with the end table
lamp I mean it loses the luster you know
with whatever chick you're with after a
month
you know so I always have different
combinations of light so I gotta get
Joey D will you learning something
tonight that's you're absolutely right
let me tell there's always music 24 7.
oh well even if it's low
you know what I mean that it's just
going because that's what life is you
got to just keep going yeah you know so
I I keep there's always a soundtrack
going on in my house when you were young
growing up was there always music on you
what was that in the ass in those days
when you guys seven eight well well when
I get up like to have coffee with my
mother
oh he's asked me like so did your father
have that mouth and that attitude it was
really my mom
you know she'd sit at the kitchen table
I'd wake up on another day I just found
an excuse not to go to school
and she wouldn't even bother me with it
she got you know pour some coffee and
she'd be smoking like a 120. she smoked
these like Virginia Slims
and Sinatra would be on that was uh um
William B they would call this DJ and he
would play Sinatra for hours like Sirius
does it now yeah you know so that's what
would play you know
you know when you get up in the morning
like 12 1 whatever it is you know
because she was a late Riser too so
that's why I could get away with not
going to school
you know and then I come out of my room
I go I can't I can't believe I like
forgot to go over there
and look at this the snow flurries you
really want me out in that and she loved
the company so she'd go you know what
pour a cup of coffee you know and we'd
be listening to Sinatra
that's different
different words
do you you reminded me of this [__] when
when I did Joe's podcast when you
started singing the contents oh yeah of
my balls is on your face my wedding song
the bottom of your ass is a very fine
place you have a great voice he really
does he really can sing and he swings
she gets hungry for [__] at eight
I grew up in a house with music on
and this house I'm living on does not
have music what I have music in the room
yeah
so besides the lava lamp I got to get
you something to play music no no I
brought this over here see that was my
little I got that the exact one [__]
tremendous you put that it's amazing
yeah and it's black that'll blow blast
and I brought him over here but I do
want to say because we just like got
into the music and everything but I
gotta say I'm thrilled to be on your
shoulders oh I've been looking forward
to it I know we got to postpone our gig
you know in San Francisco right but
we'll make it up but yeah and I was
excited about that because what was I
telling you on the phone about him what
he's gonna do in front of me and then
what I'll do really and Destroy them
yeah and he told he said I'll tell Joey
don't leave nothing yeah I'll say don't
leave anything so I could just sort of
come out and relax [__] you know no
he likes to come out and just ride that
wave you know yeah I'd rather I'd rather
come out after like Eleanor was a killer
on stage I've been telling her lately
yes I go you know it's becoming like
hard to follow because you know I I got
when I come on stage I go to nothing I
don't care I don't care if you got a
standing oh if they if you just crush
them I'll I'll take my Applause because
they feel they need to do that
and and then I'll just go to nothing
I'll take a few minutes just to walk
around relax it's almost like he reset
the time how many years of stand up
Andrew uh nearly 40. 40. wow do you know
what the experience is he could control
everyone
when he used to we'd be behind The
Comedy Store and he'd go tonight I'm
gonna go up there and watch what I'm
gonna do I'm not gonna talk
I'm not gonna talk
yeah yeah I would go home like and say
let's say it like this isn't for me
why why does he want to go up there and
talk Jesus Christ I don't know how many
times
I can't believe he got me stoned out
before we even give me give me another
hit I'm in a cloud of smoke oh yeah
but uh maybe you'll hire me I don't know
what's happening control on stage all
right give them confidence absolutely uh
listen man there's a couple people who
break down comedy for you and Andrew's
one of those people like behind The
Comedy Store on those stairs with the
cousin oh yeah John Barris and he would
just School us on little things and I
would go home and go what the [__] was
he talking about because he was telling
me about things like I wasn't ready for
I was five years ahead yeah I was five
years behind about getting to that
control
but when he told me about the [__]
I'm gonna go up there and not say dick
that's how I became a storytellingly
yeah because I went home and took that
onto the belly room one night and said
that's the control level not saying dick
for years you could tell an amateur
comedian he wants to run up there and
tell his material yeah I've seen people
grow slows down no matter you could like
listen Isis could come into the comedy
store and blow up the corner and Andrew
come up
and wait and suck him into that world
just it's a [__] gift no it's true
it's a 40 it's a 20. it takes about 11
to have the balls to [__] you know
especially in a big room you know
Tuesday at the Librarians Club don't
mean Victor nobody but in front of 200
people on a Friday at the store when
you're just following Margaret Cho or
whoever you know it's a hot night yeah
yeah
I was the guy that always followed Eddie
Murphy you know at first I'd have to you
know beg Mitzi to do it
you know but then I was her guide like
to follow Robin Williams
Robin Williams Eddie Murphy and Richard
Pryor when he came back from the burn
incident
you know if you know after that
and honestly I didn't think twice
I just I don't know what it is about me
I just look at everything as a challenge
well you know and I I and and I've told
this story before when
um
the last time I did the Howard Stern
Show
he says to me because even after all
these years I still baffle him you know
I just see it in his face I mean he's
the greatest but I still get him with
[__] because he says this is like uh
after the Woody thing happened and and
people were going ah you're gonna win
the Academy Award all this and I'm like
no I'm not
I just wanted to do a great job and and
that's how I really feel about those
things but if they did Woody you know
because they already did another special
I did Entourage the final season so the
Woody thing like blew it up
and Stern is asking me he goes all right
so let me ask you a question dice he
goes you'll build your career to an
absolute pinnacle
and then you'll destroy it
like why would you do that
and my answer was
for the Goof yeah just to see if I can
go do it again Jesus
and there's no guarantee of that
no but you've done it like yeah and now
I'm at that point again that's what's
going on now but I'm not gonna blow it I
I I'm not gonna blow it for the Goof do
you remember 10 years ago
everybody kept saying that they were
going to release the [__] Marlin
brand little tapes of him teaching an
acting class in the valley oh that's
hilarious no yeah for a while before you
died it was a very secret acting class
and he taped all the classes and for
years people were going to release them
where we [__] up Andrew
was not putting a camera on those stairs
oh my God because that was my college
101. you told me a story that you're at
the store one night and that they call
you at the house and they're like hey
it's Michael Douglas he wants to go do a
movie oh no he wants to go on the fourth
of July and don't bring a jacket and
then you you can smoke it in the makeup
chair no no I'll give you that
no no I don't know the beginning they
call no this is Corey okay okay princess
Corey calls me and says let's win who's
princess you don't want to know what do
you mean you don't know he's 27. he
doesn't know princess she used to be the
town coordinator
oh no I know I'm helping them the
listeners this used to be the town
coordinator at The Comedy Store yeah
because you two are so high right now at
least yeah sleeping I think
I don't know when he had me smoke [__]
but but even if these colorful lights
weren't here I'd be seeing them yeah
yeah he doesn't smoke anything like I
feel like I'm in a Doors video I don't
know what's happening another hit of uh
Joey Coco's pot I'm sorry he's so high
right now it's hysterical to look at me
too wait so this is Corey calls you
Talent coordinator at the comedy store
and then go ahead okay tells me that uh
this direct uh Michael Douglas is
looking for me
all right so I call him up I can't even
believe I'm getting it and you know I've
already done like I've been in the biz
it's like 1990.
2 000. it could be two thousand yeah
okay so I go in and I read for the part
he goes it's a formality I got I got no
problem reading for the part it's with
you you know it's Michael Douglas movie
it was called one night at McCool's
so I get the [__] part
which I was thrilled to get and now they
send me to meet wardrobe in the valley
which was cool was right over the hill
from Beverly Hills I went with trainee
they checked me out with makeup
um and
the makeup girl says to me
you know um you're gonna be in makeup
about two hours a day because we put
these tattoos on you I go yeah no
problem as long as I could smoke and
this is a long time ago already and she
goes oh well there's no smoking in the
trailer
I go well there's no way I could sit for
two hours and not have a cigarette you
know so you know if we got to get our
own little Trail let's just do that but
you but this was also a time where
people were still like if they didn't
like dice you know they you know they
would they would look to attack and I'm
trying to be nice haters big haters so
um so now I get another call in a few
weeks and I'm sitting out at my pool let
me lay it out for the people I had a big
mansion in Beverly Hills on an acre and
a quarter
which is like unreal I mean I'm from
Brooklyn you know what I mean I I didn't
grow up on an acre and a quarter of just
grass it was Unreal yeah so I'm at the
pool with my uh with my wife Trini
people you gotta understand I'm all
[__] up right now
if I'm telling you a little slow it's
because I'm all stoned out okay so
anyway the greatest part in the world by
the way if you Joe you should start
selling the pot on the show oh please
that's the next I would pay a lot of
money for that so it's your dealer so
any so anyway I get a call we're sitting
at the pool Max is a little baby Dylan's
a little baby
and I get a call they want to see me in
wardrobe and makeup
and I go yeah okay I'm coming right over
and they go no we'll roll the way out
like they were like an hour away
somewhere oh geez and I'm going are you
[__] kidding me with this
I gotta get in the car so you see how a
shirt looks on me you know I'm sitting
at a pool here
but I'm like all right I don't want to
have a problem with Michael Douglas
right so now I go
because I'm always making friends
I'm just always making [__] friends
so I drive all the way out there
and again
you know the makeup Lady starts with me
well we're not going to be able to have
you on trail I go then let's just sit
the [__] outside how does that sound
well you put the makeup on we'll just
sit outside
so now I get a call
from Michael Douglas
and it gets me on the phone and he goes
you know I don't know what's going on
you didn't
start filming yet
and I go yeah what what's the problem he
goes well I heard you're antagonizing
you know the makeup and the Wardrobe
women
there you go
they're starting with me
I I
I'm the nicest guy in the world when I'm
not on stage you know and they're
starting with me tell me what I'm gonna
do how I'm gonna do it he goes and he
goes you know let me tell you something
dice he goes I went to bat for you on
this film I go who the [__] asked you to
you know I don't know you you know what
I mean I'm glad you want me for your
movie but I didn't say hey you got a
good bat for me and tell people that you
want me for this [__] movie I go and
I didn't do nothing I go look I go Mikey
I'm the only one that calls him Donnie
so anyway I go look Mikey
take it easy
I got I straightened everything out when
I come there don't worry I got this
covered and he goes okay because you
know I really want you for this film but
you know I can't have you know Anarchy
on the set you know
so this is what I do
you know I would mix I would make all
these mixtapes oh yeah and the movie was
called one night at McCool's
so I make them the morning tape which as
I told you earlier it sort of we're
doing a call back here so the Sinatra
stuff it's the McCool's morning tape
that they could play in the trailer okay
all the Sinatra Tony Bennett
Bobby Darin Louis Prima
Liza Minnelli singing and the world goes
around and around
and around okay
now they got the mccools after lunch
tape meaning nighttime which is all the
70s disco leading to crazy house music
so I come in there not only with the
tapes because I didn't know the setup I
buy them these giant [__] boom boxes
that light up
all right
so we put on the music
and now here comes Matt Dillon he's the
star of the movie
and he shuts the tape he just comes into
the trail and he puts on some [__]
odd [__] you know like artsy and I
look at that and I I love the dylans
both of them you know imagine you know
the greatest but I said what are you
doing
you know he goes no I want to listen to
this I go yeah but who asked what you
wanted look what we were all doing well
I go to six people in here we're putting
the [__] tape on it took me hours to
make that tape will you make the tape
yes what it's very important what you
made the table yeah I would take CDs and
I had a mixing board it's like these two
CDs if you date them we'll make you one
too yeah I got a couple of them and I
mix it onto cassettes so it's like like
a real DJ okay
so so bottom line is Matt really didn't
give me a hard time because everybody's
looking at them
you know and I said look at the boom box
I bought these [__] people it's
beyond belief you know but I did decide
at that time
to [__] with Matt Dillon for the rest of
the shooting of the film and um
he did a movie
oh wait I gotta finish what happened
I will come back to Michael Douglas no
no because that's the end now
so I I get these boom boxes I play the
music for everybody I straighten out
[__] mat because he know you know I'm
dice that's it you know we're gonna
listen to what I want to listen to and
um but he's the coolest guy but I did
keep questioning him about a scene in
the movie My Bodyguard
it was a constant okay
remember The Bodyguard he did it like
when he was like no no
he was a kid like 19 years old whatever
he did a movie to bodyguard My Bodyguard
My Bodyguard where he's like this tough
guy and he picked on this like nerdy kid
and the nerdy kid got a this monster of
a bodyguard so then Matt Dillon gets his
version of that guy
and and what happened is
Matt Dillon's bodyguard
you know through this motorcycle in a
lake
that The nerd's Bodyguard like really
took time like this old [__] bike you
know motorcycle and he threw it in the
lake in the movie
so I come over to Matt Dillon but you
know I stay on it and I go man let me
ask you something
I go you know the movie My Bodyguard wow
it said you know you know the movie My
Bodyguard oh no I'm [__] I'm showing
him Matt Dillon in the movie we don't
have to go to the Internet okay
Matt Dylan's face
how young he is that's why I don't go
out with you no more I'm thrilled that
we don't go out anymore this is why
because when I'm doing something you
start doing something I'm trying to get
to the point of the story
[Music]
point I do I do you know
you know the movie I know exactly what
the [__] I'm saying all right
the boxes are lighting up no no no no
Dylan
I say yeah I know this show I know that
I know you know the movie so I go over
to them and I go you know that scene in
My Bodyguard with Mike
gross the motorcycle in the in in the
lake and he goes yeah and I go like you
know like what's up with that
he goes what do you mean what's up with
that Echo
you know they clearly wasn't bothering
bothering you guys
you know and you sent them over and he
just throws them I mean this guy just to
find one part for this bike took him
like five years oh yes that's right and
he goes so what do you want to know I go
like what's up with that why'd you do
that
and he goes like the Y is like his Y is
in his mind were like he goes dice you
we're doing a movie together now like
what do you mean what's up with it I go
no there'd be no reason you know you got
your bodyguard the kid had his and for
no reason this guy's going over and
starting in
like why would he do that
20 years
of fun
cracked them but you know who I really
cracked this [__] stiff yeah you have
to tell it yeah it is [__] stiff
who's in the movie think of his name and
it's not about his talent
um Paul the [__] is his name he had that
sitcom
Paul Riser right all right so you knew
him Paul before yeah I know Paul since
he started right you know Paul you know
good guy great comic but he's you know
he's very you know he's [__] affected
by like what he does I don't know it's
the only way to say it he's very serious
you know so he's on the set and at the
time he was doing all these at T
commercials
okay
no like he had it was you deal for him
you know I'm sitting next to him at this
bar in the scene and I I go you know
that thing you're doing like with a t
that's like that's a good deal you got
going on there like I wish I had that he
goes no it's really it's very lucrative
you know I go
so let me ask you something what are
they like just like deliver crates
you know like of these phones it's like
a five-year-old like for your friends
and everything and he goes
they don't give me extra phones
I go you didn't put that in your deal
like like you get like a crate of phones
like your family and your friends
because no it's just a money deal you
know I go well let me ask you this
truthfully because this is when there
was also like you know the house phones
were big too still
and I go so what happens like what do
they got a guy in like an ATT like when
he sees your bill
he like makes it disappear when they're
going through him
and he goes what are you talking about I
go you know like when you send in like
the the check with you know the bill
like they must have your name up
somewhere that when they see that they
just like to rip it up and you know
no
I'm going I would have that you know why
would I pay for my phone if I'm helping
them out getting them customized
so now what Paul Reiser would do is when
it was time like not to be on the set
he'd never come out of his Trail he
didn't want to see me
yeah
you know so I would you know like at
that time he likes smoking cigars and uh
so I would like just bang on his
dressing room door just to jolt them
onto the trailer
because I know he's like all chill
inside with the cigar and I'm like [__]
yo and I'm banging on the door and I'd
actually run away so we wouldn't
unless he listens to his podcast he
never knew that was me
so
wait a minute so now that I've made some
friends on the set
uh the craziest parts coming
because Max
my son Max
and John Goodman's wife
gave birth the same not my son my Max
didn't give birth he was born Trini gave
birth to Max and John Goodman's wife
gave birth to their daughter the same
day okay
now I didn't know that I come up you
know Trina has the baby they put you in
like one of their like
you know hospital rooms for a few days
yeah and um but I had
all these armed security guards on Max
like xfbi you know because I was getting
a lot of death threats what was the
height of his career yeah it's when I
was doing the Arenas so there were two
guys where all the little babies are
with the black suits on and you know
like who the [__] and then there's two
guys on trini's bedroom because I had
some serious threats at the time
so I I come walking down the hallway you
know and there's John Goodman standing
outside I guess his wife's room
and he sees me and he goes oh now I get
it
you know now he gets it like he didn't
understand why there were all these uh
like they're carrying Glocks these guys
it's newborn babies like what's going on
up here you know and that's how I meet
John Goodman now a few years later
actually five years later because it was
going to be Max's fifth birthdays when I
was doing the one night at McCall's and
he was the other star in the movie and
John Goodman's the greatest he's one of
the greatest actors of he's just a great
guy but you know I could ruin anything
wow
and so Max's fifth birthday is coming up
so we're making a big birthday party
as I say to John I go why don't you come
over with your kid and your wife and
whoever you want I'm making this giant
fifth birthday party he goes and he goes
yeah that sounds great whatever
so he wasn't at the party
okay so and and there was no guarantees
coming to the party and I know that but
I love to I can't help it I need
something to do on the set when I'm not
filming
so I see John Goodman and I started
given a little attitude yeah how you
doing you know and he goes no good
you're right I go nah you know
what I don't want to say nothing you
know
remember
we were going to share the birthday
parties
and he goes
not dice I said maybe we'll come by you
know I said everybody I had over 100
people that everybody was waiting for
you
even the Batman I hired hung out
and the Power Ranger hung out because
John Goodman's coming
I mean that well the celebrities there
you know but the point is your
daughter's five Max is five and you know
all standing around putting a lot of
thumbs waiting for you and you just say
[__] you Dice [__] you [__] your family
and he's looking at me going I'm not
that kind of man
if I told you I was it was like in
passing conversation like did I take
your address he says you know I go it's
not the point the point is you said
you're gonna be there
and yeah now he's looking at me I think
the guy's like you know he's starting to
get heated up and he's like well look if
I make plans to do something I go
through with those plans but we to make
definite plans I go you know what
Matt Matt was right next to me should I
go get him
let's go Matt Dillon I go you think the
guy felt like he was on [__] trial
getting his morning coffee you know and
then I look at him and I go I'm just
[__] around how you doing everything
good is this like first thing Monday
morning yes immediate how did you get
seven in the morning that film and do so
well well I have all those people hating
me because I played two characters and
the second one tried to kill everybody
with a machine gun yeah yeah yeah that
was a good scene so anyway with Michael
Douglas when he shows up on the set
because the boom boxes and the tapes
all of a sudden he's got his hands over
my eyes he's like guess so that's
happened twice in my career with the
Guess Who one was Travolta one was
Michael Douglas
so he goes guess so and he goes what
what has happened on this set because
people are more excited about you being
on this set than Matt Dillon look what
happened everybody's turned around I
said I told you it's all going to be
good I got the Disco tapes I got
everything you know what I mean I get
the boom boxes I I know how to come to a
set I go it was just that makeup girl go
go straight in her out so me and Michael
get kind of tight right so after the
movie
he's going to take
um Katrin oh what that was just funny
Jones you're right to to Europe for her
birthday oh yeah yeah so I'm smart you
know I like the guy I want her to have a
great birthday so I make him birthday
tapes for her
okay she does make a hell of a tape no
wait a minute I make a birthday tapes
then I go to a
um a sex shop I figure I'll do a little
shopping for them you know and I buy her
this this hot [__] number I know how
she looked in it every [__] detail
that's the worst thing you can do to
some buy lingerie for their wife yeah
but this wasn't normal lingerie this was
no Victorious secrets of Fredericks this
is the real deal this is me going the
street
you don't think that's offensive like to
buy a woman did you ever see her yeah
yeah we all did yeah yeah she's hot I've
seen her exactly so what am I gonna get
a row but terry cloth robe I gotta say
you okay with this if somebody bought
Terry lingerie you'd be like oh thanks
hey Terry go put that on
okay you know what he's loving the story
can you let the man love the story all
right fine go ahead
all right you're buying her castle so I
find that it's hot [__] number I
could just see like how her ass cheeks
would stick out because that's you know
in movies you know I studied them a
little and like uh that one she did like
it was not Cabaret Chicago Chicago so I
saw her in some outfits I'm going all
right I did they're not the biggest
thing in the world but I can make them
look great you know I mean they're nice
they're normal they're regular big tits
they're not like you know kettlebell
tits or anything like that that you look
and go what the [__] is that it's an
actual yeah
big [__] tits banging between your
head you know what I mean so I get it in
negligee
and then I pick them up
you know some like you know the best
lube in the world
it's the kind of lube that if you put a
little on your fingers it'll be on there
10 years from now it doesn't dry it
doesn't believe in getting this is true
I still have some yeah I'm not going to
say the name of it unless they want to
pay me a million [__] dollars but I
call it silk but that's not the name of
it because that's what it feels like
okay
so I get them mad I throw a Toyota in
just to you know make the box look right
a couple things that you know vibrate a
little with stuff like he can't go into
this place and get it so I figured that
so I give him the box to give her right
so now
I'm watching TV
okay not even kidding and it's like one
of the entertainment shows like
Entertainment Tonight and they're
showing her birthday party in a disco in
Europe with Sean Connery
and Michael Douglas is talking about how
they're playing
dice's disco tapes
that's what's being played in this disc
attack because I really blend them and
mix them and uh and then I get a call
from Mikey saying it was the greatest
[__] birthday she's ever had I go
tell me you gotta tell me how the outfit
look he goes it fit perfect I go and the
other thing I put in there
the silk and he knew exactly what he's
doing he goes it's you got to tell me
where to get it's I told him like where
to get it yeah I go but you know I don't
know if you should go in there so you
call me and I'll get you like a dozen
bottles whatever
but I love that guy you know did you
ever [__] think like you told me once
that you started out as a travolt
impersonator yeah did you ever think
like now you have your own show and show
time all that surpassed
did you [__] ever think this all
started with your dad driving you to
[__] beach revolta at some roller
skating rink no it Pips is where I
started yeah Comedy Club the Jerry Lewis
Center Travolta
honestly I I just got to tell you the
truth I believed I was gonna be as big
as I became
really
that was not that was not a hair of a
doubt
what I was what I was meant to do it's
more of a spiritual thing in me that I
knew from really young
and
this time around is like I mean that was
insane you know the arena days like like
I was telling uh yeah yeah tell them
because there's a lot of people who are
young yeah you're allowed to talk right
of course I'm allowed to talk um but
what does that mean no I'm not he is
allowed to talk
I like him a lot I love you I want to
hear Lisa
it's not a question but it was just
because I asked Joey we were talking
before the show I said could you compare
him to anyone now just like big like
celebrity wise because we were watching
the dinosaur well I thought you meant
stand-up wise and I didn't want to give
you the wrong figure he had said the
figure on JRE and I I just didn't
remember and I didn't have time to he
was coming I didn't want to show up and
we'll look at his numbers up or whatever
oh okay so I wanted to so as we would
know
I wanted Lee to understand at least you
know Lee what year were you born 88 ew
right that was all right the the Rodney
Dangerfield special I was on that blew
me through the roof
Ed February 13th sadly February 13 1988.
when's your birthday July 20th that
wasn't okay so you weren't even born yet
no but I know what that special was
gonna do because I was really prepared
for it
you know it's like I I've never been the
guy when you tell me you're going to
give me an opportunity
I mean
I build it in my head and I take it to a
certain level
that there's no there's no stone left
unturned okay
so when I got the Rodney special and
I'll never forget getting it because I
went on at The Comedy Store to Showcase
from
and then you know you want to hear from
him did I get it did I get the special
because his specials made like Kennison
and and Seinfeld and Roseanne and all
these Big Time comics
you know
and so when when I showcased I came over
to Rodney who you can't get a straight
answer from and I'm going so Rodney what
do you think because you're wild man
okay
don't go no but did you like it you know
you're all right man okay funny you know
and I go yeah no and I'm following so
now I wait I don't want to bust his
balls but it did get to the point where
I said hey Rodney you got to tell me am
I on the show
do I got the show and he goes you're
gonna be great man okay you're gonna be
great
so I get ready for this [__] thing
like I'm going for the heavyweight
championship I'm doing physical training
on top of going on every night at the
store I didn't care if that it was a
packed house I didn't care if there were
two [__] people in the room I
wouldn't care if the room was empty
just that I could practice because the
one thing I I knew was anybody being
filmed getting a shot of a lifetime is
gonna be a little nervous I'm gonna be a
little nervous so I don't want to worry
about the jokes I don't want to even
think about the material all I want to
think about is the performance what
people are seeing in the houses
and
I knew the first night so when I got
dressed now now I do the Rodney show we
stay at the Regency in New York
and I was with trainee and I put on the
whole outfit I wore with this giant
[__] Holly Davidson Buckle the
glasses everything I said to Trina you
meet me at the club I want to walk the
street and feel it I'm gonna walk there
let me tell you something when I walked
out of that [__] hotel you could feel
people looking you know it was like a
[__] superhero coming down the Buckle
is the size of my license plate on my
car okay the glass is a bigger than my
head whatever so I come walking into
danger fields and they're just setting
up and Rodney's there and he comes over
and he goes how you feeling man you know
and I look at him I go
tonight they get disciplined
tonight Rodney they pay
and he looks at me and he goes
okay man they're gonna be disciplined
okay you're not mad at anything oh yeah
you know it goes and he just kept
repeating they're gonna pay tonight okay
I got that you know and I knew after the
first show and it was funny because um
you know Barry Sobel was on that special
oh yeah and he tried to wear motorcycles
right that's right you know and Rodney
goes over to me and he goes what are you
wearing tonight man right and I said
yeah I'm gonna wear this he goes if you
can wear that you're not going to be on
the show okay go get your baseball
jacket you know dice where's the leather
you know and um
yeah it's almost like all day like he's
just gonna Slaughter
you know and I'm like so [__] I just
want the camera on I just want to
introduce the world to dice and it's
exactly what I did
and the show Ed like I said February 13
38. and within months I was on sale at
my first Arena was Nassau Coliseum
which is 18 000 seats
my agent who is a rock and roll Agent
Dennis offer you know handles Billy Joel
to this day Metallica all these giant
rock but even he was like why do you
think
you could sell he goes Billy Joel sells
out Nassau because I called him up I
said what's a play I did 1500 seats in
Manhattan a place called Town Hall
now I call him and I go what's a place
like Madison Square Garden but not the
garden and he's going well uh you got
Nassau Coliseum out in Long Island but
Billy does that
Comics don't do that and I go well why
not
he goes you just did 1500 seats why
would you think you could do eighteen
thousand but anyway he gets rondellsner
one of the biggest promoters the world's
ever seen to uh
to do it you know without putting any
money down on me he goes you know I'll
give you guys 90 of the door
you know because he wasn't good you know
guy did me with 1500 seats I'm talking
about 18 000 we sold out in 43 minutes
she he's gone how did you how did you I
just just a big ad in the newspaper
there was no internet there was no
tweeting there's no radio no you didn't
do it no radio okay but I'm saying like
today it's all with the Twitter Twitter
and Facebook and [__] I didn't follow
anybody you know they just followed me
into the Arenas because they never saw
anything like it I never saw anything
like it other than in rock and roll with
with Elvis that's that's how I learned
stand up by watching Elvis and watching
him perform in other great people like
that like you know in drummers it was
Buddy Rich it was Gene Krupa you know
and then it it was actually Ringo Starr
to turn me on to the drums and then I
got into those guys what is your first
thought when you when you just first
here at least sold out 18 000 seats in
43 minutes yeah that's crazy well I was
I was
in Vegas at the Hilton
doing like I had to do like a show for
uh a video company that was gonna put my
video out because we made a deal ready
for my special
and um which was the Dice Man comet
and
so I was in the Hilton hotel room oh
this is so funny sleeping in the same
bed with my buddy hot tub Johnny because
we had to be there for the one night so
they gave me the sweet so we had like a
pajama party
and the phone rings this is hysterical
and Johnny picks it up and it's my Agent
Dennis
and Johnny's like yeah hello yeah oh
hold on Dennis he's right next to me and
I'm looking at him like you [__] what do
you mean I'm right next to you we're in
bed we're in a king-sized bed you know
so Dennis tells me you sell that man 48
minutes or 43 minutes whatever it was
and and that's when we now just went on
tour the dice rules tour which was a 26
City Arena tour which sold out in I
don't know a couple hours
every tour would sell out in a couple
hours
it's crazy it was the craziest thing I
ever went through in my life because of
what happened with the press that they
came after me like like I was an ex-con
or something not a comic it was the most
ridiculous thing I even went I couldn't
even fight it because I'm like what is
this you know so I'm trying to entertain
the fans and you got the Press you know
calling it The Comedy of hate and I'm
going it's anything but hey
The Comedy of how much I love [__]
really and I and I did some gay jokes
that weren't gay bashing it was just
that time in America where gays were
coming out of the closet so it was a
funny subject matter like today they
call it like cross-gender you know what
I mean transgender transgender but I
would you know back then make I'd call
them trans testicles right like oh you
meet the girl of your dreams your whiny
you're dying you put your hand up a
skirt you're holding a tree trunk what
do you do then
you know it was just a joke you know
when I would talk about bisexuals I go
well you do wake up in the morning flip
a coin heads I want hair pie tails Falls
across the nose they were just funny
jokes you know but but because it was
that time like Ellen came out of the
closet at that time so so it was very it
was a very sensitive time so everything
I did was put under a microscope
you know but I wouldn't bend why would I
[__] bend you know what I mean I'm
entertaining I entertained over 12
million people in Arena shows that's a
big deal to make people laugh like that
that's a big number and you know it it
was a crazy time but I'm glad I did it
I'm glad I'm the first the original you
know and there have been a few guys that
you know people always bring up Madison
Square Garden so first and that's a big
deal because it's the most famous arena
in the world
but I go what about the other 299 you
know what I mean what about the other 12
million people you know but the garden
was was a spectacular it was complete
pressure on me because it wasn't just
that I did two shows they were also
filming it for a movie so it was the
stress and pressure of making the garden
like I've been there a hundred times
only I wasn't you know into a movie you
know an actual concert film I mean Eddie
Murphy did uh which one in not in the
main room of the garden he did the
Paramount which was like 6200 seats
right I'm doing 18 000 people and
even Eddie Murphy would ask like how
that how you know he was always a fan he
was he's one of the greatest ever and he
would go how do you sell out 20 000
seats tonight I go what are your movies
make 400 million I'll switch you know I
don't got a problem switching but I
studied bigger than life performance
and like the attitude I have on stage
just to tell you something like I told
you how I studied Elvis right king of
rock and roll leather right then you had
guys in film you know like like James
Dean and Marlon Brando and then when I
got a little old it was Travolta and
Stallone you know but you know
that image was done on TV with with
Henry Winkler playing the funds but that
image that that bigger than life
attitude image was never done as a comic
and because I liked acting you know I
would use the comedy stuff I just wanted
to develop my acting chops I didn't even
care about stand up
you know and the dice thing took off it
it was [__] nuts you know but but to
me it's like acting it's just playing
you know I don't walk around with 9 000
rhinestones on but on stage I'll wear it
because I know they're not going to see
their neighbor in that you're not the
guy next door you know and I just wanted
to create a bigger than life Persona a
comedic hero for people to really laugh
and the people that got the joke that
it's so ridiculous there's so many
loopholes and every joke I never I don't
write down material I don't work on it I
go on bear and bits develop over time
but it's organic you know my rehearsals
for my shows
oh when I actually do the concert
because I don't know what's going to
happen you'll like that too Joe you go
up there and destroy people I'll find a
guy and I always name him Joey yeah and
I just dig into his life and all this
[__] comes out
you know like if I'm dealing with a guy
let's say
it's married 37 years
right I see what the wife looks like
sitting next to him
just [__] awful it's nearly four
decades and through the show I find out
about this guy and I find out about how
you know he's never had an affair in his
life
and the guy's like 70 some and I look at
the guy and I'll sit down because I get
to like know these guys through the show
and I go you know Joey but not Joey Coco
the Joey in the audience I go
you know we've been talking for a while
and
I really love you
I mean like family
I you don't even know what you mean to
me I wish
like maybe we were hanging out for the
last 30 years I love you more than my
own brother I would kill my brother for
you
that's what I would do
I go but because I love you and because
of what we're talking about I mean some
of the things I tell you
you're not gonna like too much
in a lot of ways Joey I tell them
you hate yourself
that's what I gather from this little
meeting we've had here
and I feel like the audience feels the
same way
and you just see the guy's wife shaking
ahead like no he doesn't it could be
their anniversary and Joey's just
startled just looking at me going like
I'll get guys going I don't hate myself
oh really
am I the one married I've been married
37 years but to different ones I break
it down I give one seven I give 110. I
don't do the whole stretch with the same
[__] thing night after night no
matter how many [__] lava lights I
got in my room they've already heard
every playlist I got if the you know
four or five [__] years what are you
gonna do with it you gotta trade around
like a baseball card like when we were
kids and then you want to sit here and
tell me you don't hate yourself and in
37 years never had a [__] Affair
never even got jerked off in a closet at
work in the pencil room
whatever the [__] they got in a real
office building you want to tell me that
you love yourself that you're willing to
go to your grave and the only thing and
I go nothing against you ma'am I'm sure
when you were 23 you were the hottest
thing on [__] Earth
you know but today but but you know you
look in the mirror every morning just
like everybody and that's what he's
still gotta [__]
do you think he loves himself when he's
got to bang you when he's gotta look at
you again
37 years break it down what how many
times a week how many times out of the
Year [__] banging jerked off [__]
her in the kitchen while she's doing the
dish throw it back at the dish where's
that romance Joey
with the romance of [__] run your
countertop caddy cornered the same
countertop that maybe people will be at
24 hours later for Thanksgiving dipping
like chips and Chip and you know what
you did to that filthy animal you know I
get into the head
just so romantic oh well the whole Act
is Roman pretty much I mean I was gonna
say do you do a lot of Valentine's Day
shows
I gotta ask you two questions real quick
yeah
what was the release date of The Dice
Man cometh and that was taped in
Philadelphia correct that that was New
Year's I this the Rodney special aired
February 88. let me get a penalty you
got a pen over there because I got to
figure this out here pencil closet you
gotta get in there
so so especially uh Rodney specialist uh
sadly February 13th 88.
okay and then my special ed New Year's
Eve
at midnight
88 going into 89. like at midnight wow
so how many months later was that
hello what are we figuring out
time frame nine or ten
then give me when did I love time frame
like I'm being questioned when did Ford
failing come out
um what was the release date that was
July 90.
Jesus Christ wow I was still in the
[__] halfway house I'm just figuring
it out yeah I'm from the figure I'll
give you the answers I'm gonna blow your
[__] mind MTV situation that was also
that was 89. oh when I got banned for
life I couldn't tell you in a month
though
Okay so
New Year's when his special gets
released I'm locked up
I don't know who I don't know I don't
know oh you've told me no no I don't
know nothing I don't know nothing I'm in
a [__] age unit yeah that's why I
celebrated New Year's Eve at the camp
because they had kitchen and drinks and
food and everybody that was cool oh
right HIV there's only four guys with
HIV
but they had cable TV the whole the
government had to do a whole thing for
them yeah so I don't know nothing I get
out
I'm in a halfway house and the dude from
Jersey my roommate older than me keeps
telling me you got to see this guy dice
I'm gonna [__] handful hands I got
time for the [__] die all right dice
is only gonna get me in trouble yeah it
sounds like trouble but he always was a
big stand-up guy he took me to see the
guy from Boston this is very interesting
he took me to see the Dead Pan guy us oh
Steven Wright yeah one year he won
tickets from the radio show and then a
year later
he takes me again and this is weird I'm
with the same guy
and we walk out and he goes what'd you
think it was great but he said the same
[__] jokes as last year Adam were
walking across the street with me going
if I was ever a stand-up comic I would
change my material up a lot like at this
time I'm not even Andrew I'm not even
not even thinking about doing this this
is something that's I listened to
Richard Pryor and Belzer not Bowser the
other guy David Brenner and oh yeah man
and you know whatever and then all of a
sudden I get locked up I come out and
I'm he's my short of my roommate I lived
there before I got locked up and he's
telling me about this dice character
I'm lying to these people I'm supposed
to be at a [__] car dealership
selling cars with a suit on I'm slinging
coke with a [__] car yeah with a
pager they call and they're like where
are you they couldn't get I had a
special permit from the court saying
that I could leave I didn't have to be
at a certain like most people go to a
job job oh yeah not me I have a garage
but if you went there it said come again
have a good day
yeah and I would have my car and I'd go
to people's houses and hang out and
watch TV
and one day he convinced me he goes just
sit just watch and all of a sudden you
know the [__] thing and I'm watching
and he's sucking me in I'm watching I'm
like okay
and 10 minutes in like you know like I
had to go but I didn't have to that was
it I was hitting the stand-up comedian
his material and once the [__]
material came up about
he came up to me at the airport if I
wanted to buy a thing a plant yes so I
could stick it up your ass or something
I lost it it was like uh that's it that
was my breaking point like I knew I
could do this what this guy was saying
this is what I'm thinking as I walk
right around I have this I mean some
things people think
I'm an only child Angel so as I'm
walking up to you I'm like look at this
[__] milk in the back of my head you
know what I'm saying I got my own
dialogue but it's real like it's [__]
real like it it [__] torments me it
torments people so yeah I watched the
first 26 minutes maybe 24 minutes and I
said I gotta take the tape oh
[Laughter]
this guy's like my brother at the time
he was dead when I got sentenced I don't
want you to take it out of the house
well these are hard Commodities to get
yeah so I had to cut a deal and I'm in a
halfway house
so I'm in a halfway house February of
89. I finally watched the dice tape
maybe May of 89.
they cut me loose
but I come up positive for cocaine from
weighing it okay and they put me back in
the halfway house now this is where it
gets now I've watched this special at
this point I know it backwards and
forwards right I could turn it off and
[__] write the [__] thing up
I went to the halfway house and I go
what the [__] are you guys gonna do New
Year's Eve
and they go oh we don't know I'm gonna
sit in the rooms we all got to be in my
head oh listen what if I rent the room
and get Chinese food brought into this
[__] and we watched Andrew Dice
Clan I remember these like these guys
are like yeah yeah but the girl's like I
don't know they were like females and
this is the same chicks that I would
knock on that door they'd open up the
door I'd give a Coke and she'd drop suck
my dick right at the door I'd be the
lookout for myself when she was
something and then she locked the door
like just slammed the door and I'd walk
away this is the same girl like I don't
know if I want to watch that he's pretty
dirty New Year's Eve I had maybe it
started with like nine people in there
but before I knew it there was maybe 40
people in there wow and we watched the
whole special and I remember like going
to bed not doing drugs not wanting to do
drugs wow not wanting to do anything
pretty much but I knew that once I got
out of here I had to try the stand-up
comedy you know since we've been doing
the show four [__] years people
always you know people always stop me at
every Club I go to somebody goes listen
you uh
you know listening to Lee you inspire us
to do this so to go back to school yeah
it's the same thing with Andrew
if I wouldn't have seen Andrew Andrew
pushed me over the cliff like that was
it and I brought the tape home my wife
was the whitest chick in the world in
those days now I came out of prison and
she was on she was like the mother okay
she became a den mother yeah yeah she
wasn't my wife anymore right I remember
putting Andrew on living room sit down
yeah and I have to wait three minutes
she's like no
I'm not watching this that was the
beginning of our divorce like that was
it yes that was it like in a
subconscious way yeah in a very
subconscious way I knew that this is it
this is my dream
S
I made her drive me to The Comedy Works
and I got on stage and this July 18th
will be 28 25 years wow and uh yeah and
then like I'd go up to The Comedy Store
I become a regular I'm up there you know
Eddie Griffin's bumping [__]
Eleanor's up there giving orders you
know people being in the back those
[__] jamokes oh the kid that from
Tennessee but also Andrew Dice Clay
started to come up there and I wouldn't
really say much and it was hysterical he
always came because I'm gonna tell you
how I [__] know listen I always Smell
Trouble
I could smell trouble I mean I I made
enough trouble right and I see something
like I just make a mental note check
that and I just walk away it's got
nothing to do with me
Luca palanca shows up oh I love daily
but he does a bit and he would go in his
jacket at that time take a [__]
barbecue uh uh yeah I can find a
cigarette on stage and I remember it
deep down inside he would say I'm sick
I'm a hit man from the Brooklyn and you
know he would wear a leather jacket and
it was cute for a while
and uh but when you take the lighter out
I knew it was gonna be a problem yeah
yeah and then Mourinho showed up oh and
Mourinho started doing his thing and uh
I'll never forget this and one night
dice is up there usually dice was always
up there with his cousin or a [__]
manager or once in a while the wife
this night he's alone and he's [__]
prowling
he doesn't have a heavy jacket on he's
by himself
I've never said a word then six seven
months go by I don't say two words this
gentleman yeah I don't need to say
anything to him in my world no pictures
no selfies no [__] talk to my
brother I want nothing I didn't say a
word to this guy I would watch him I
would watch him at night I would watch
him go on stage I would watch him just
everything about him watch him that's
that's how you learn you shut your mouth
and you watch and yeah I had Coke I was
gonna go get a package of two from
Chewie I ain't gonna lie to nobody but
for right now even though he doesn't
know what I'm watching him yeah and I
know there's something right
and both of those guys are gonna line up
that night
and Scott day is lurking ew and Scott
day comes on it's about 11 30. okay it's
got Day by that time he would put away a
ball of tequila sleep on one off yeah
and come back out I gave him a bottle of
tequila one time that [__]
that's how you got spots that's how you
got spots on Monday you bring them nice
tequila bam five spots he comes out
right there I see Dyson and having a
conversation but it's kind of getting a
little heated on dice's angle
and what the conversation was about
wasn't about theft
it was about persona
and I knew it was going to come up like
I had seen it I'd seen it on the Veil
but Andrew had not seen me at the time
yeah I didn't know you I'm already doing
dice I'm doing the core is Andrew Dice
Clay the the you know some people gonna
take one though some people go to karate
some people go to Jujitsu my martial law
at that time was Andrew Dice Clay but
you're trying to Blossom out of that
yeah but the bottom you just said the
key though to keep what was it okay
you could be influenced by it I told you
a bunch of my influence oh yes I got but
I'm not doing them right you become an
original you become an original yeah and
so I love what you're even saying all
that I influenced you like that is a big
deal to me whenever a comic tells me or
anybody tells me even actors you know
when I work with Bobby Carnaval recently
in vinyl tell me what I meant to him
tell me how he was at the Garden you
know when he was a kid and I was on
stage you know told me how he he like
they'll take things from me and turn it
into Bobby kind of Val he told me all
this and and and and look at him one of
the great actors now but he's an
original he's himself he's not being
somebody where you go what is this guy
doing dice or any actor or any com you
know you want to be known for who you
are what you created because a lot of
times Joey even if you take on anybody's
Persona and you act like I used to see a
guy that that tried to act like Let Him
in all the time oh yeah this [__]
charcoal [__] there was a lot of them
but no but they're specific yeah so
anyway
it it's hard enough to make
uh anyway good it's hard enough to make
it in the business right but let's say
you fail you don't want to fail 15 years
later going I've been doing somebody
else for 15 years what if I was just
doing me
maybe it would have been a different
story because once somebody does
something you know once I became what I
became in the world of Comedy it's not
going to be another guy like that that
guy's never gonna look there were so
many singers that came after Elvis
especially when he was in the army
look like them sounded like them and you
never heard of them they put out a
record but nobody heard of them and then
Elvis came back
and it was Elvis again
tons of tons of bands that came out try
to be Led Zeppelin let's say never heard
of them because we already got Led
Zeppelin we already got Elvis we already
got dice
you know so why would I do a special
with you when we got dice yeah you're an
impersonator of that
you got to be in that's what you did you
used the influence you win the influence
you know and you turned into Joe Diaz
the comic yeah like I've seen you uh a
hundred times on stage I never think
dice ever even from the beginning I
don't think I thought I mean
you were as ballsy as could be you're as
loud as can be maybe that's what you
mean but your your personality Shines on
stage and that's what I've always seen
even from day one even if you felt an
influence I got all my influence did for
you is give you the opportunity to say
all the things that were in your head
out loud
well well or twist your reality and make
it you know your stage Persona that's
all you do
any good comedy any good comic any great
comic comes from truth in their own
world their own life you don't have to
talk about your life
but you're gonna take things even when I
talk about sex like I was telling you
about my bedroom in the lavalant so I
will take it and make it a cartoon for
them to make them laugh at what they do
to each other because people put they
put so much upon sex especially today
I'm just laughing at you yeah I want you
to laugh a Sunday night at the store one
night okay and these three little Asian
dudes
sat at stage right if you're on stage
face a mitzi's gym but they're over here
and Andrew goes up there and he's
[__] throwing you know bombs and
sucking dick and people laughing and
also they look so open this to be
[__] Chinese guys
and I don't know I remember one line was
you know that if I eat your father's
foot he goes what what's your father on
the restaurant I think he goes yeah
that's it that's it they just [__]
threw gasoline like a
but the best was in Vegas
it's a table for the gay guys
and he's [__] going off on this stuff
and he's talking about in Vegas they're
gonna build the casino
20 minutes
it's gonna shoot come no hotel casino
[__] and fag's gonna be in the bottom
going on
that would be the big hotel [__] it
opened up in the potatoes exactly hotel
casino
because of all the themes in Vegas you
know some of them it's still a good when
I say the jacuzzi look like
I can't remember
it was black this is this is where it's
really gonna get [__] up like
I learned so many lessons
sitting like three chairs down from
mitzi's oh God yeah just sitting there
and watching Andrew go off at night and
Paul Mooney like just I came home last
week and at breakfast I told my wife and
I gotta tell you something at 53 years
old
I can't tell you how honored I am but
I'm still [__] working on it even if
it's twice a week that's all I need just
to let me know you're still living you
know people animal he says why aren't
you going for more spots because I still
remember coming down here and there was
those 40 50 euros that were down here
bitching about Mitzi not giving them
spots yeah lurking and signing up on
them angry angry and I go I don't want
to be that guy I want to come down here
and have a great time every time I want
to come down here as I'm coming down
Laurel King I don't even listening to
music
yeah I'm thinking about like this
[__] thing listen dog if it wasn't
for the comedies I had nothing like The
Comedy Store was my son's Anarchy like
that was it once I got a taste of that
darkness and that you you know you're
[__] in there and also here's the guy
that influenced you
and those lessons like still some nights
I'm a little [__] up about stand up I
know what it is yeah I gotta go to the
back of the comedy store I smoke one of
these um
stoked where you just watch the comic
and get sucked into his world and you
[__] either die inside
or it makes you want to go home and
[__] open up that notebook and that
pot of coffee I have seen three
which is one of my favorite things uh
come in high on shrooms and just sit in
the potluck section in the back of the
original room that's the what's the
learning watch like Open Mic or
something and I'll come in and he'll be
like this
like all just messed up inside himself
watching taking it in I mean taking it
in it's like it it takes him down but at
the same time it's like he knows
my life I never every morning I get up I
clean the cat with the boxes I [__]
smoke a number I make coffee I wash my
[__] every after everything's get going
before I walk the baby to school I sit
down and I just write about what the
[__] I gotta do and at the end of that I
always go I can't believe I did
something with my life
right
about that that's it just did something
in my life like that's it and it all
came down to that [__] Comedy Store
like that was my church I mean that was
it that's it that's it yeah he would be
there every single night I mean I waited
everyone was there for 12 years and he
was there almost every night and that
was during I started 93 he was still one
of the hottest you know if he wasn't on
the road he was at the store yeah
whether he was hanging with his wife I
do a show a concert at the LA Forum okay
at the end of the show I did some music
I like to you know play drums I do the
Elvis thing
at The Forum Slash from Guns and Roses
Duff McKagan from Guns and Roses come on
stage with the band I had from Brooklyn
We rehearsed in the afternoon we did
Elvis together and then we did um
Santana Soul Sacrifice where I played
big drum solo and slash plays like a the
meanest [__] guitar so and he's gone
back and forth with my buddy from
Brooklyn and these guys couldn't believe
they're on stage with Guns and Roses
yeah but Guns and Roses didn't even do
the LA Forum yet like when they showed
up to rehearse
they were like we've never done this yet
you know what I mean like they couldn't
even believe it but my whole point is
you know where I was after the LA Forum
I could have went to any club any
restaurant any disco whatever
I'm on the back steps of the [__]
comedy stuff
an hour later like it never happened
because that's what I like to do it's
humbling like like you know wheels will
always say to me he goes you know
it's amazing what you've done in your
life and that you went through that
whole down period and now you're all the
way back up there again
he goes but I don't even know why you do
it because there's nothing you really
want to do
like you know like when he'd see me at
the back of the comedy so he'd be like
why are you here like if I was making it
like you I'd be in the fanciest [__]
restaurants you know with 10 people
serving because you just want to sit on
the back stairs I go I I didn't make it
so I could go to restaurants I go it's
about what you just said Joe
accomplishment that you did something
with your life you know and
you know like when I was with Eleanor
those were really bad times career-wise
okay thank you and plus no I don't mean
what you said I mean honestly okay Jesus
it was awful when I was with titless
over here
you [__]
tits over here keep me happy yeah
tits over here let me explain something
let me clarify this [__]
you know when I was with Eleanor it was
like the worst time in my life but not
course of Eleanor I was I was obviously
going through divorce the career was
down in the [__] toilet I didn't know
which way to turn you know but how could
I make this shittier I'll date Eleanor
no no no but Eleanor had nothing to do
with it that's what I'm making the point
of saying and um but but I wouldn't bend
I I would like persevere and and look
for all different ways but also it was
about bringing up my sons yeah you know
so I really didn't give a [__] that much
about the career I just cared about
making money to pay my monthly nut you
know so I would I'd go through the clubs
or whatever little theaters would have
me that's how it went
but my thing and this is good for you
too was always about Max and Dylan when
that happened because my thing is about
teaching kids by example you know and I
would tell them I said where do I step
on the gas pedal again you're going to
see something you've never seen in your
life and that's what they've been
watching not at 21 and 25
and over the last six years what they
saw me do and they're doing it for
themselves with that band still Rebel
and
but if I didn't do something they'd be
doing nothing because that would mean I
didn't teach them I didn't I didn't take
on the responsibility all I cared about
was getting another movie getting a
pilot [__] that he let it affect you so
you got a kid so that's your reason no
this is yeah this is my no this is my
deal this is my deal with the kid the
kid comes first that's right right
that's what I'm saying to teach the kids
oh absolutely like you were talking
about being in prison now you got
millions of people listening to you on
your own podcast you sell out theaters
you got a real career you're not some
some Monday night amateur anymore you
you turned yourself into Joey Coco Diaz
that's a big deal in the world of Comedy
yeah I talked to a lot of guys they'll
piss on you and they'll piss on you
because you got millions of people you
know and they got nothing you need those
haters I'm telling you but absolutely
but forget about it but forget that
forget about that you have the reason to
be see you say when you got family when
you got people that you love and they
see you knocked down like my family saw
me it was like the story's never and I
don't care how many Arenas I did back
then that's the old story that's the old
dice story I was going to build a whole
new one you know and nothing was going
to deter me that's just who I am Hey sir
and you're that kind of guy I wouldn't
say it to a guy that's not like that you
know because there are people that just
They Ride other people's waves you know
what I mean and that's okay but guys
like you guys like me girls like Eleanor
they make their own way oh I don't know
what to me is the best female hey guys
country people and comedy people always
have to give you a spark what you do
with that spark yeah and uh Rodney what
you gave you the opportunity in a
lifetime you went on that and [__] up
that room that's it that's what country
see I didn't even play the room yeah it
wasn't about the
when I filmed
you know I'll never forget because you
know Mitzi it could be no [__] good
at times I know she's older now and I
love her
but the night of that special the night
at a Rodney special I took a walk
to The Comedy Store again I wanted to be
alone and I just wanted to walk and look
at all the people on the street because
I knew what had happened I knew that by
sometime the next week all those people
are going to know who I am I know it so
coming to The Comedy Store
and when I see Bob Schimmel right nice
the funniest greatest so so he sees me
everybody else the other comment a lot
of jealousy immediately that night that
was Joe but not from schimel
he looks at me and he goes so anyway
dice the special a is right there's a
special ed like an hour ago you know you
go so the phone rings you know I go all
right here we go and I pick up and he
goes it's my mother and he goes yeah
mine she goes are you friends with dice
I love dice you know and he just killed
me with that now I go and I sit down
mitzi's at a booth and she's fuming over
the special
you know because I'm waiting for to say
what I because I knew I knew when I
filmed it how it was going to affect the
country I can't prove it to you other
than the ad I took a daily variety two
days before the show aired I took it for
Thursday because in Show Business on
Friday nobody shows up at the studios so
I figured let the ad hit on Thursday
full page in [__] Verizon imagine
full page of variety full page and
variety and why are you laughing at
least have to sleep over there let him
sleep I'm going to sleep no he's just
fine
so what happened is I take out this ad
half the page was my picture and in big
bold letters it says I never studied
much in school
I go but when I turned on the tube and I
list all these things there was Elvis
the king Buddy Rich with hands like
lightning Gleason uh uh Cagney you with
the great one Gleason you were number
one you know all these different people
I looked up to and then at the end it
says Murphy and Pria both great no doubt
but in 88 it's dice Thou shalt and I I
put the name of the special variety yeah
I put that in variety to the entire
[__] industry because I knew how big
it was before it ever came on TV I knew
it the night I filmed it first show at
dangerfields left nothing
because you know that's how prepared you
need to be when you could hit a home run
you know I wouldn't have settled for
being in the middle that could never
happen in my world I would have quit but
a long time ago
but I know if I did it right it'll be
the biggest thing so I put that in
variety that's my proof so now it's
Saturday night the show is
I go to the comedy still I sit down with
Mitzi and she goes off about I can't
believe I don't have a credit and you
know they should have done it here not a
I don't like the look of it I go you
know what Mitzi all I give a [__] about
it's how the whole country got to see me
tonight and I'm gonna go have a drink
which is very rare for me
you know because she should have just
gave it up at that moment she just said
congrats yeah because she know but but
you'd also know Mitzi now I'm at the LA
Forum she's in the limo with me she
flied to see me at The Meadowlands she
flied to see me at Madison Square
because she came everywhere with me
after that yeah it was nuts
but but I know but but I only knew
because I was that prepared you know if
you're getting ready to do a special by
the time you do that special you
shouldn't be thinking of your material
just think of the performance think of
the the whole country watching you and
perform for them move around do
something make it a little exciting for
them even if it's with your backdrop you
know don't just stand there with a mic
it's only that was my big complaint with
Comics that they didn't understand
performance because I grew up with music
I grew up singing playing the drums it
was all about acting had nothing to do
with stand up so when I would see all
the comics when I came out here like the
Paul Rises and you know uh Seinfeld who
I think is one of the greatest ever you
know
what what I didn't see was performance
you know and I I can't go on a stage
without performing somehow I can't just
go up there and do a routine I would be
bored to [__] you know I just would be
bored if I even thought about my act the
only thing that happens right before I
go on is um wheels will tell me Well
Eleanor's on stage just kicking ass like
she does every night so maybe some of
the toughest crowds in the country my
fans and she destroys them all the time
every time and wheels is backstage with
me going now you go out there and you
tell them something now and I go what
and sometimes a lot of times we've been
smoking the weed before I go up so I
could just let my mind go you know it's
going you tell them the way it is and I
go but about what and he goes you know
exactly why you just tell them when you
get out there you let them know it now
and that's how he'll psych me up for the
show and then I'll pass down and go
she'll pound me you know and I'll go I'm
just so [__] Stone right now and he's
telling me to tell them something and I
don't know what it is he wants me to
tell him
and that's why that's why there's a few
minutes when I first go up there well I
don't even bother with them
like even if they yell out my name I
don't look I know I'm up there
I don't need to hear my name shut up
little I'm ready we're gonna get through
this together that's how I look at it
because I don't know what's going to
happen and I know you'll like that too
Joe no that's the way it's supposed to
be do you get high before our show I'm
high on a [__] day
let me give some shout out to you let me
get back to this real quick I want to
give a shout out to my man JT my man
Matt Baker Dan Bakersfield BJJ Tony
callejo Joey Riley
I don't know Sammy Deluxe Jesse
Mike Vincent Daniel ronkowski and Lonnie
Thomas I love you [__]
now tomorrow do me a favor oh yes
tomorrow 10 A.M
Andrew Dice Clay is doing the Coney
Island Amphitheater Coney Island it's
brand new it's a brand new and brand new
Coney Island they still got the hot dogs
the whole [__] deal you got the beats
the whole day I'm not playing Nathan's
no I didn't say that but playing an
Amphitheater
I'm selling the whole night why do you
got to get in between this one don't
touch you anyway I don't care tomorrow
morning 10 A.M
these tickets are gonna go [__] fast
the the code is Dice d-i-c-e again
d-i-c-e where do they go Lisa yeah just
go to Andrew deskley.com Andrew Dice
clay.com tomorrow 10 a.m Eastern 7 A.M
California time and it's I gotta tell
you it's the first Amphitheater uh the
first room I'm doing that size in about
18 years yeah
yeah and it's all you know I should tell
you this was because of getting on The
Tonight Show doing The Tonight Show and
uh Jimmy Fallon number one the greatest
him his producer Michael Cox they
couldn't be nicer and when I was
supposed to do the show you know because
dice the TV show was coming out you know
the network wanted me to sit on panel a
little and talk about the show you know
and I was like no they want me to do
stand up I'm not breaking it up the
whole thing's like six minutes you know
what I mean so I I told the producer I
go what what's the most time you could
give me to do stand up if you really
want me to do stand up and it goes five
minutes that's the maximum and I go all
right and I go through through this
material with him
and
when we were done
this this is cool I asked the guy go all
right once you get it all approved can
you like you know write it out like in
an email and send it to me
because what what Michael didn't
understand is
I was winging it giving him the material
I wasn't sure what it because I can't be
dirty you know what I mean so I came up
with some material like a week before
Fallon you know but I wanted to give it
this this dramatic opening that people
would think I'm gonna destroy my career
in a minute okay
so I do the set and it winds up the
longest set that tonight shows ever read
six minutes and 23 seconds and that was
without Fallon's introduction and he was
so excited afterwards he was like
jumping on my back behind the cart you
know just the greatest guy I just I just
want to hang with him all night him and
his producer and the producers you know
texting me you murdered it and all I'm
nervous is about that that they might
you know cut it down like edit it yeah
they left every [__] word in there
all right this is one shot on The
Tonight Show this is what hasn't been
done in years now I'll tell the people
out there the the concerts I'm doing
which you could also see on my what's
the name of my site Andrew Dice clay.com
yeah so um
the concerts I'm doing on this little
run in May are like between a thousand
and fifteen hundred people a night which
are great size you you do those rooms
you're a superstar in comedy oh yeah for
the most part okay
after the Fallon show I stayed up all
night got on the plane by the time I
landed
this Amphitheater was booked that's how
nutty people are going from this and
this is a 5 000 seat Amphitheater it's a
new building so I'm really psyched to go
back to Brooklyn where I come from where
my family's from and really just bang
them over the head again because I
really on The Tonight Show if I'm gonna
go on there I got to reintroduce the
country to dice that's how I looked at
it and this guy let me do it
best guy in a long time I always had a
problem with Leno because he didn't help
Comics you know you know the deal I
don't need the the bad mouth him but
bottom line is Fallon loves Comics you
know so if you could get that tonight
show you should do it Joey because it
changed
I keep thanking the producer because in
in six minutes I changed my career again
you know everything's happening my show
it looks like it's a hit people are just
loving it but to go back into to concert
at a time where I really feel people
need it again because we're living in a
very angry world is is really exciting
to me you know and that's why you know
like we were gonna do you know a show
but uh we're gonna do it again and I'll
take you all over if you want to do a
bunch of concerts it's just really I
know you do it on your own but you're a
powerhouse on stage and I love that I
love all that stuff too so Eleanor
you'll have to go on before Joey I uh I
love that the constant this whole thing
has been standing up for you Andrew and
and I never expected it that's the whole
thing that nobody does
that's the thing that I see people
that have been here since the time I got
off the boat here and there's still here
clicking and making a living but stand
up has always been a constant and for a
couple years [__] will happen and for
two or three years [__] won't happen
then for three years
and the whole time I went through 18
years of that and then the whole time
but the whole time you're getting
stronger yeah but that's what I'm saying
after you're getting straight but you're
going through another two decades you're
getting stronger with this comic you're
getting more confidence on stage and
remember three the best stand up I do is
when shit's not going good that's the
best stand up nothing to me is more is
funnier than when you hit a crowd that's
silent
and then not laughing like those late
nights at the comedy store when I could
go up there and there wouldn't be a
chuckle and I could just chill and do my
stuff for me I like that you feel that
like I I'm already having anxiety about
the late night spot that I have at the
store that's going to be quiet
yeah but it's it's like [__] you know
you feel like yeah you don't need to
development
the 11 45 I got 12 45.
I'm just telling them 11 45 so 115 spot
at the comedy store oh wow if you do
that four nights a week
that's life let me tell you what the
equivalent is that's like going to the
gym I get like about four yeah dead
lifting
squatting and benching
400 [__] pounds and eating kale
that's what these spots yeah you know
those punishment spots when you you know
when Andrew was 10 years of that yeah
yeah that's what I would do and I did
nine you know when Andrew goes up
those little [__] half a [__] Comics
would leave oh yeah this is I would say
those are the guys I would stay I would
say watch watch
go out get water get a cocktail come
back Watch Andrew and then they'd be
looking for people and I had to follow
Andrew yeah and Andrew would walk out 16
people I watch you though I would watch
it nine would stay yeah and you have to
figure it out and that figuring out is a
[__] a a year at Yale that that's
what Yale wants you to do to think on
your feet that's the top thing that
that's it it just wants you to be quick
that's a four-year [__] degree and
meanwhile you're sitting there going why
why I could be in Philly with my family
celebrating Christmas why am I here the
21st of December why and then you know
you have like an idiot like you know
some idiot a comment could go you'll go
I can't believe I'm waiting here [__]
Eddie Griffin's bumping me right and
you'll go I can't believe it's 115 he's
about to get off
and somebody will go you know what you
don't want your spot
oh yeah there's always somebody waiting
oh yeah always somebody wait and you
have to think of it that way I'm honored
to still be oh yeah me too I love it but
I do get a little anxiety still so
that's what it's all about okay listen
I try listen in the bottom of my heart
you go to other comedy clubs around town
and
I go up like nothing happened
[Music]
that's anxiety twisted
because if I don't get caught sick I
tell you why I start getting anxiety
those five steps when I woke up and I
step to the left by mitzi's chair yeah I
get anxiety now but those are the sets
I'm gonna [__] level you yeah and
once the anxiety come I take three or
four sips of water and I I breathe I
breathe I turn around and I look at the
light I make sure that I could see that
there's a door open yeah and I breathe
and once they say coming to the stage I
still have a little bit of solid breath
yeah that's the kind of noise you would
have loved it you would have loved the
Westwood comedy star
it was the best what would go on there
because you know
because nobody's watching no it was it
was run by you guys right yeah I got I
got um
one of my one of my best lines from the
alleyway
outside the back of the comedy store
there was an alley and then an arcade
like you know you understand in Westwood
yeah yeah so um there used to be this
comic Andy Huggins
today we have Dave Taylor it's basically
the same person hilarious tall like that
thin like that you know what I mean
angry and so Andy Huggins picture like
Dave Taylor you know what I mean and and
this comic Joey Gainer
so
you know a thing they used to do at
Westwood is that Andy would just come on
Joey was a thick guy you know he's not
that tall but you know you know he could
throw a punch if he had to you know and
Andy would just come up in the middle of
Joe he said and draw him over the front
table
and scream at him and walk out of the
club that was like the little bit they
worked on okay yeah like picture Randy
pictured Dave Taylor coming up and
throwing you over the front day can that
really ever happen so anyway
I'm I'm there you know Ronnie Kenny no
you don't know Ronnie one of the old
school you know like August from that
generation so Ronnie would love drinking
[__] beer and hanging out real Irish
two-fisted [__] guy the best you know
great funny funny you know so anyway you
know he's about six seven B is in
everybody's hanging out Joey's On Stage
Here Comes this guy Andy Huggins throws
him over the front table you know and of
course the people that would go to
Westwood were like college kids from you
know yeah so Joey goes over
hmm
Joey goes over and all of a sudden he
starts choking
so he goes out into the alleyway and
he's on the on the floor just choking
you know because what had happened is
one of the wax candles
poured into his mouth from a table so
it's like being suffocated but and
there's Jackson Perdue is there I'm
there call a bow is there Ronnie Kenny's
there Alan Stevens is there and the
guy's basically choking and nobody's
doing anything and Ronnie who's on his
seventh beard just goes hey Joey if you
can't party with the big boys don't show
up and I just fall down laughing like I
can't put the way he said the line I
wound up making it like a hook line in
my first special Dice Man cometh with if
he can't party with the big boys don't
show up and it wasn't about somebody
choking on wax it might have been you
know somebody choking on your [__]
instead but that's where I would see
like I would just study all these people
and if they said something like like I
remember when you started saying it's an
old expression but you made it your
thing with who's better than you back
then you know what I mean and it was
like yeah yeah like you know like who's
better than me who's better than you but
it worked for him like he was instantly
when you started out you were finding at
least something some kind of hook line
which is the most important with comedy
you know when they could leave and
remember something you said like even me
when I go oh the word unbelievable you
know the way I would say it they'd start
saying it you know and that's how you
hook an audience I gotta get I was in
the [__] halfway house when Ford
Fairlane came out
did you ever leave this halfway house
they put me in there yeah
from February of 89. look sometimes you
gotta stay long whatever February of 89
until like August of right okay here it
was I stayed in there from but then he
got recharged yeah I stayed in there
from February of 89 to when
to
until I got married they released me the
Tuesday before the [__] Saturday
so I got married September so they let
me out there September 5th
but once you get married
89 no but September September 5th I got
married in September September 9th which
one no we didn't get married second one
nine nine eighty nine I got mad wow and
but three four days before that I got
released in the halfway house I stayed
out for two months then they put me back
and they violated me for 90 days so
November December January I got released
all three
and then they threw me back in there
again February of 2003 no of uh 93
83 no no no no
no oh he's high no oh it's fun to watch
90 90. okay so then they put me back in
there may of 90. until about August the
[__] 90.
but in that time period I remember there
was two movies that I had to be
responsible for one was good Fellas now
I read the book good I've seen the
[__] 2020 when Henry Hill was on
2020. so when I got locked up the book
was in the library
I read the [__] book and a month
later People magazine said that it's a
movie so I waited and I remember like
checking like you had to make up 10 lies
and you couldn't drive
I drove well when you're in the halfway
house you're not allowed to drive in the
federal halfway house I drove I didn't
give a [__] I had a car parked three or
four blocks away that was an emergency
call so I walked everywhere else but if
I had to meet somebody I got my [__]
car and I remember one day pulling up
next to a chick from the halfway house
like one of the guards oh and praying
please don't look over and they wouldn't
even say nothing they won't say anything
until you walk in then the cops are wavy
they're not supposed to say that unto
you if they see you do something illegal
and [__]
yeah they just report you so the whole
time you're out you're thinking they
didn't see you so
but I went to see I would go eat Chinese
food and in those days they tested you
for reefer and drugs I had a system I
would sweat every day in those days I
used to run the Boulder Creek Reservoir
so what I used to do is I would take a
joint I had a garage by the halfway
house but I had way before I got locked
up I had a garage and I go down I had a
heavy bag gloves a little boom box I had
a bench maybe 200 pounds maybe two
dumbbells
and if I picked up a victim from time to
time I get my dick sucked in I had a
joint I had a joint man that would last
me a year
a month for that [__] garage it was
it was a play it was better than going
with Jim yeah I had my own little
[__] him in there so uh what the [__]
I would go in there I would take a hit
off a joint now we go to a Chinese
restaurant eat and I would go to a movie
theater
oh wow and I remember like
Ford Fairlane oh I was in the halfway
house Good Fellas and there was another
movie I snuck in to see Batman
now Batman came a little later with
Prince and all those people jumping up
and down that was oh yeah that did the
94 or five something like that but last
week I flew with a dude
and we got into a conversation there was
Comic-Con in uh Indianapolis last
weekend and we got done conversation and
he used to be a comic at the store from
80 to 87. and he said to say hello to
you that he rented you a joke Maurice
he's a voice-over guy
all right I don't know he might want us
joking you rent oh no no no no no no you
talk
um he you went up to him and said listen
I want to buy that you threw me off and
he goes no no I didn't say it how about
I rent it to you no it was a guy I was
hanging with that claimed he was Maya
Lansky's grandson which is a whole other
story and I was supposedly doing that
Danny Constance
my grandson no but but yeah it was
nobody but he really played it you know
and so when I was supposedly doing
Carson
he went over to Maurice you know because
we had to like put together like these
five minutes or whatever it's gonna be
you know like cleaner material yeah you
know he was lying this guy was just a
pathological liar but he goes over to
Maurice and he goes you know that Rocky
bit you have he goes uh I need it for
dice in a week
and he goes you don't know how hard it
is to come up with a bit I'm not just
gonna give him I'm not giving him my bit
he goes what about if we rent it
you know I forgot how much he told him
he's going to give him
but then Maurice called for the money
you know and obviously there was no
cause and shot I never did cause and and
Lansky he called himself Lansky and he
got mad at Maurice and he goes now I'm
just taking the bit take it up with my
grandfather if you don't like it
just like that that's a whole story I
wrote a script called Comic in the con
years ago about him yeah you know it was
just great I can't it's too long to go
into but that's uh the Maurice's bit but
we never rented it and I never did it
who's better like who walks around and
going I want to rent you a bit
that's free for a night yeah to do on a
national television show when there's
four channels yeah like if somebody did
that today there's a big chance the
reason Maurice called us he wanted to go
see Howie Mandel who's very close with
in Vegas so we wanted the money for for
the airline and everything and and now
I'm just taking the bit and when he hung
up we're going these are friends
we're not just taking a bit you can't
just do that he goes I could do anything
oh you know are you really a landscape
absolutely I don't know a little distant
cousin
[Music]
oh are you even with us right now
absolutely I told you that's what
happens to him yeah
see that picture look at his eyes
[Laughter]
picture you you do stand up right no not
at all why not I I don't think I'm that
funny
I don't I don't think I'm that kind of
funny really okay
I like doing this like I like like the
reason why I think you like doing this
and sleeping yes that's true you gotta
go yeah he's got a Mexican girl he's got
a big party to plant for her tomorrow
right yes
for weeks let's see that really yeah
what are you gonna get her pinata what
are you doing tomorrow with her nothing
with little pictures of Lee in it
how come for what it's Cinco de Mayo how
long you've been going with this
three years you argue a lot with us no
never no she's not combative at all no
she's really cool and she's Mexican yeah
I don't know and she's [__] lying to
you yeah Joe tell him tell him
Joe Knows Spanish from the [__]
I see I like them but I straight stay
clear
how come good temper they just don't
work for me it's too hard it won't it's
too hard I seen a Latin woman in action
I've been living for almost seven years
does lee lee do you get beat up no well
here's the thing I think I could see her
doing that with someone but we have we
have similar like likes it's like so we
don't argue because it's like hey do you
like
watching TV and and having a star and
getting Thai food it's like yeah that's
what we like so there's no real fights
there I've always Andrew
uh yeah but you can't you can't be like
a pansy
I don't think you are but don't ever get
to that level I think I think that you
know what I mean like remember remember
Joe you know what went on in Rebel
with James Dean oh with the father when
he's on the [__] knees picking up
broken [__] dishes you don't want to
become that guy on your knees with a
with a [__] apron on you know what I
mean broken dishes and James Dean is
like grabbing them by the shirt College
just going get up
remember that I
and he's got what what's the problem son
I need an answer now get up
and that's what I what what I'll tell
like people in audiences when I see them
like just a folding
you know what I mean a man's still got
to be man and that's it you don't want
to be that guy because they'll take it
to that level where you're in the the
red and white played [__] apron from
the kitchen bringing her food it's
bringing the mother food in the [__]
bedroom like a [__] [__] this
[__] guy no sir James Dean wants to
ask him something and the father's
crawling around the floor picking up
little pieces of glass and James Dean
just grabs him by his collar and he goes
get up
tremendous
but you remember that right you can't be
that man I can't I mean they want to
play games in the [__] bedroom all
right I'll go along you want to smack me
back I get it
off and look at look
as a as a 13 year old my phone he's
[__] who is today in love with the
Spanish chick and I wasn't even banging
the Andrew how old were you maybe 12 13.
me too wasn't even banging a dry hump
and a second little tit from time to
time if I did that she'd still be with
me and I [__] got left back
that's how good the little dry hump
[__] okay can I tell you my Puerto
Rican story okay so you know
you know I I we just moved back I lived
in Florida for about seven months when I
was 12 with my family and we moved back
to Brooklyn so we had to stay with my
grandmother
Avenue M and East 12th Street in
Brooklyn real old time brick upon
Eleanor was in that building yeah I took
her in there to check it out with my
boys when they played in the laundry
room we went down to the [__] all
right so anyway
what happened is I really loved the
superintendent had like three daughters
and I really dug one who was like my age
but you know how you looked at him at
that age like they were the hottest
thing in the world you know any girl
like through through a 12 year old's
eyes I was actually 13. so I sat on on
the wall right next to that bedroom
window on the first floor in the back of
the building and that wall faced uh uh
[__] in uh where they bring dead people
you know what's it called a morgue a
morgue so I'm in this [__] alley that
creeps me out to start with because the
limos coming in every 10 minutes with
another one and I'm sitting there for
about three hours till I finally say an
assist is it there and a little
brother's there
you want to be my girlfriend she goes
yeah I said no great and I jump off the
wall and I go back upstairs because now
I got a girlfriend you know you walked
away from her
no because now I asked the question it
took me three hours to ask her
it's like the first girl I asked to be
my girlfriend so you know you're sitting
there and you want to say it but the
sisters are there and you finally blurt
it out so I go upstairs but now I won't
come near this girl I'm afraid to go
nearer because now I'm gonna have to
make out with her
right so
assistance who are older than her
one day they take me down to the
basement you know because the the
elevator would actually go past the
lobby and go right to the basement which
would never happen today and in the
basement where all these like you know
rooms boiler rooms with doors and so
they take me and they put me in a chair
and wanted assist is goes all right
we're going to teach you a little about
kissing
and one sister like holds my head back
yes and the 19 year old goes to give me
a kiss
and I felt a tongue but I never felt
that so I blew it out of my mouth and
she starts choking on her own tongue
that we had to pull her tongue like a
sister pulled her tongue out why did you
do that because I didn't know what it
was I didn't know what a tongue was in
my mouth right so this goes on for about
two weeks that that I don't go need a
girl and finally she chases me down for
two blocks and says can we go back to
being friends because at least this way
I could hang out with you because I
wouldn't make out
too young
and I regret that Mom and Joe you should
and did those girls repeat bringing you
down no not after one nearly died
it was Latin to me I loved I loved Latin
girls I mean you know I was with Eleanor
but that was like a different thing yeah
that's when you want it to go out no it
was crazy because I have always Irish in
Spanish
I like Irish I like Irish Terry's Irish
yeah I like irishness my son's mom is I
love all that Jersey Irish [__] with red
hair and freckles on it too yeah and
dirty I love it I love all that freckles
oh [__] I love it I love it there you go
[__] nuts too they try to play games
you know what I mean then they [__]
nut all over your [__] chin and you
feel like a man what do you think will
you do these things to the Mexican yeah
is this way he has to Cinco de Mayo
you're gonna have to get a little pinata
my eyes are burning Are we almost done
what do you mean your eyes are burning
go open the door for your cigarettes
you're killing me open the door get some
airing I mean actually so get up out of
your chair and go open the door one
thing that's gonna go over there just
five minutes are we allowed to open the
door you can open the door open the door
once the uh
yeah
[__] just open the door open the
[__] door double team now I'm getting
mad oh
that's what I love about her she's the
greatest
so this whole time whether this
generation knew or didn't know you've
been working yes Vegas
[__] whatever and now
about to kick off a few 1500 seats I
don't know open it all the way for the
love of Christ what's the matter
yeah so the first the first part in the
store is 1500 seats but now we're going
into these you know giant [__] places
again
you know I don't even know how I'm gonna
need you Joe I'm telling you I'm not
worried I'm here for you bro I'm I'm I'm
I'm dead serious because you know this
time around it's like I I really want to
bring like like incredible comics with
me and just that people walk out going
what kind of show this like the best
comedy show ever
that's what I want to go to Eleanor
rocks the [__] Mike Jack
do five minutes
oh you have to do it Philadelphia with
him I'm doing healing yeah yeah but
before that I'm headlining at Uncle
Vinnie's in Jersey are you gonna plug
that July 10th and 11. good for you I
mean June June 10th God bless you did
you see Eleanor in the blue comedy show
yes I did yeah my Dangerfield spot thank
you yeah he called me and told me Joey
did yeah I watched it that's why I did
that it's the weirdest thing listen man
uh
I'm just glad we connected I [__] I
haven't seen it on the computer
and there's the dice pilot so like the
Lord just popped it in my lap I went to
The Comedy Store that night I spoke I
called left you a message
and something happened
I'm watching something also tonight The
Tonight Show blah blah blah Andrew nice
clay I tape it I run to The Comedy Store
I get involved talking to somebody I
walk in the [__] house I turn it on I
go in the kitchen I get some water when
I come out I don't even have to DVR wow
coming to the stage boom
so it was like uh I was right there you
know what I'm saying watching the whole
phone oh you saw the Fallon yeah I saw
the family live I I really can't but
that guy over a half a million hits
already yeah it's like by by the next
morning it was at like 150. and now it's
over over half a million it's like
amazing I could never thank him enough
that's all that's why I'm saying his
name I think he's the greatest you know
because he's not afraid to let a guest
Shine That's What I love them let it
guess just let me [__] go I felt like
I was on it The Comedy Store I felt
nothing you know no you look like you
look loose you had this that was very
loose because
um oh nothing you know what that comedy
store there's a bunch of
professors but your education just to
see the I'm gonna do this till they put
me in the grave because it doesn't
matter I love doing it you know what
high is you you go you do it you get in
your hotel room you sleep you smoke a
number and you take a plane home the
next [__] day
so I've learned so much from you man
just this last journey we were talking
about it's a store last week it's it's
amazing but I try not to like you know
like I talked to Eleanor about this
stuff a lot like there is a lot going on
now but it's always been important to me
that I'm just grounded yeah that I am
the guy from oh you got the boys you
know what I mean and that's how I I
really feel I have a Spanish wife now
for Spanish food I I don't eat the
Spanish food I can't do it she gets you
to eat a lot what that you would never
eat the Spanish skirt steak I eat it's
just flavorful you know what you know
skirts though yeah that's like my
favorite steak no I love it but there's
like uh the Mexicans like came out with
a version of it
she marinates it in different yeah but
it's like skirt steak but you'll get it
like on the grill nice enough like I
like going to Mexican mod yes Food Mart
it's the [__] best the best
big cookies that it is Big you want to
talk about Munchies the bags you don't
find a little bag like in there yeah
that is [__] big yeah like beyond
belief cookies
Mexicans don't [__] around no more you
understand me let me read these ads and
we'll get the [__] out of here yeah
because you're not getting a back rub
because it's time no no no no no I need
you to dig I got a spot at the comedy no
when I went down when I had that fall
with my [__] arm two weeks ago
where's the masseuse at right here she's
good at it all right we'll give him a
massage while I do that we're gonna do a
spot
it's another reason we're going through
something listen can you live with that
voice
you live with it it don't matter what
you're doing this season you know you
got the the old fella tour now what's
that what do you call those people the
the whole Coachella oh Coachella
Coachella for old people oh I do want to
say you just did remind me of something
yeah I'm proud to say this about my
son's band still Rebels so absolutely
number one they got booked to do a Tracy
guns tour who who had the band LA Guns
and he was right Guns and Roses for a
year and he heard he heard a lot of cuts
from that their album that's gonna come
out well Valley days and so he he booked
them on this Victoria he's going to do
in October but just today it was
finalized that my boys are are starting
off first band at Oz Fest the final
Oscar crazy that's a congratulations
yeah I I couldn't even believe when I
got that it's unfucking believable well
see people just don't forget you know
Sharon Osbourne saw them on The Late
Late Show
about a year and a half ago
and I get a text from her last week and
I call her up and
she she didn't forget and I tell them
all the time I go these people like
Sharon Osborne when they see you just
like producers and directors that watch
Young comics and go three years I'm
coming after that guy right you know
they watch you develop you know so for
them to get this Oz Fest like I'm like
out of my mind from it
you know most guests come on here and we
laugh and we giggle this has been more
of uh yeah a talk no no I've learned a
lot in this this thing so I want to
thank you for coming on tonight you know
how come on the show anytime you want I
love you I love Illinois let me do these
things here and we'll get the hell out
of here like I said it's concert season
it's baseball season football season's
around the corner and that's when you're
gonna need what I'm about to talk to you
about what's the next big event you want
to go to like I said old Chella you know
preseason football it's coming right
back to LA all this stuff whatever it is
you can bet that it's awesome that it's
awesome that someone's going to pay less
for better seats how they use score big
you're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups and last minute
convenience charges even printed home
fees you end up paying Courtside prices
for non-seed bleat whatever what do you
call those no bleed seats score big is
here to change that did you know that 40
of all live event tickets go unsold and
did you know that there's a place to get
these seats at huge savings it's called
score big score big Works directly with
your favorite teams and artists to get
their unsold seats at unpublished prices
only with score big can you name a
ticket price and be guaranteed to pay
below box office up to 60 percent off
here's what you do one go to
scorebig.com or download the new
scorebig.com app for your iPhone and
find the event and seats that you want
two make an offer with score Big's name
and ticket price features three get an
instant answer and save up to 60 on your
ticket never any fees or sh and always
shipping is free you can count on
unbeatable prices and great seats and
when you're in great seats you will
actually enjoy the game show or oh no
you you actually enjoy the game or the
game all the more that's right you enjoy
it better [__] so do me a favor
next time you don't see any Gamers show
go to score big first and see how much
you can save for the easiest way to save
on tickets download the new score big
app for your phone and the promo Joey
j-o-e-y at checkout and you'll save an
extra 20 bucks off your first ticket
purchase no iPhone no problem get 20 off
you're on online too at scorebig.com
that'scorebig.com promo code Joey that's
gobig.com promo code Joey sixty percent
off sit with regular white people why
are you sitting up there with those
[__] Raider fans you [__] Savages
scorebig.com
cardboard Joey [__] nuts yeah anyway I'm
sorry to get emotional from time to time
you need to and this is where this app
comes in meditation is tremendous I knew
nothing about meditation I know about
smoking weed and whatever and when I
went to school in bold I used to do
walking meditation on Monday nights with
a bunch of dirty people and you know
what it worked meditation [__] works
but it's like what we do we go to church
and we pray yeah if you breathe and
saying all fall let's meditate that's
true but there's so many different forms
of meditating but listen I ain't no
meditation Guru
that is why let's be honest most of your
problems start with your mind the other
night Andrew
something weird happened to me I was
here with my main manly and we tossed
down about 750 million it was the only
reason the only reason when me and Leah
are not tossing one star during the show
is because I'm done with that because
I got high like I'm high tonight
but we started [__] around in the
second round we took a [__] uh uh
a star but when I got home
I ate like uh like a banana and I had an
apple and I had some [__] Wasabi
almonds and I went to sleep and
something happened in the middle of
night I had to get up and pee okay I get
up and pee I lay down and all of a
sudden my nose got clogged
I get up I blow my nose and I lay back
down I put the sleep apnea mask on and
my wife turned
and I could feel her finger
an inch away from my back but every time
I would Breathe her finger would tickle
my back
you know what I'm saying like yeah
I gotta move an inch away from her and
now I'm sitting and I'm like what is
this sleep happening machine broke
got myself all worked up I had to get up
spray my nose laid back down again and I
couldn't [__] connect my breathing
with my nose oh my God and I [__] had
to go on the living room and you know
what I just want to turn the TV I don't
know I just sat there like a mutt and
breathed out of my nose
and within 20 minutes I was [__]
tired I went back and I fell asleep and
all that is is you know deep breathing
is meditation just breathing but anyway
everything's everything that's why I
don't [__] eat right that's why I
don't eat Edibles after we do it that's
the balloon you put on yourself eat the
edible and let it go if it works it
works if it's not it's in God's hands
yeah right you're leaving God's hands
sometimes we gotta [__] knockout and
sometimes we get [__] like tonight
we're okay rightly you're not passing
out you're not gonna stay until one in
the morning or nothing
um yeah I'll be okay all right
he's hysterical he's a Savage let's be
honest both of your problems starting
your mind fear anger stress anxiety
depression sleeplessness they begin in
your head but they can wreck your life
but it doesn't have to be that way you
can make major difference in just 10
minutes a day that's right 10 minutes a
day this change comes through guided
meditation with the new headspace app
headspace is meditation Made Simple it's
guided meditations that you listen to
whenever you want wherever you want
write on your phone computer a tablet I
should listen to this the other four in
the morning meditation is rooted in
thousands of years of tradition with
thousands of scientific studies that
show its positive effects like improving
Focus relationship Harmony and
decreasing anxiety and stress join over
five million listen five million users
already getting some headspace for free
right now do yourself a favor download
the free headspace app and begin their
take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation at headspace.com Joey that's
right I'm talking to you [__]
about meditation because you should all
be doing it go to headspace.com Joey the
headspace take 10 program is a hundred
percent free way to experience the
benefits a meditation your busy Modern
Life so why [__] around train your mind
for a healthier less stress life start
with your free trial today right now
right now download it headspace.com Joey
again that's headspace.com
Joey headspace does not play games uh
and that's it beside that we got on it
always go to onit.com and see that I
just ordered some green living food to
throw my little milkshake in the morning
right and try to make a little almond
milk with a little [__] strawberries
some blueberries some raspberries you
want me to make you want some flax seeds
nice it takes the the swelling off your
brand new you look tremendous Andrew
Dice Clay you don't need no [__]
flaxseed you want some flax anyway I'm
in Sacramento next weekend yes
Sacramento the 12th and the following
week Pittsburgh Pennsylvania [__] get
your [__] together oh wait do we know
where I'm going
no we know where you're going the most
important [__] ticket you people want
to buy and let me tell you something I
seen Rod Stewart out there there's a
place out there that's out anyway if
you're going to be in the east coast
July 30th Andrew Dice Clay at the Coney
Island Amphitheater
pre-sale tomorrow 10 a.m code name dice
go to Andrew Dice clay.com right now to
get tickets stop [__] around yeah
because I think that it's going are you
Canadians come down yeah come down I
guess I don't know if that was my
Canadian I can't even work my own phone
okay but you're talking about trying to
promote the Keswick and uh Bethlehem
yeah do you know those dates uh
maybe the 14th May 14th oh Sans
Bethlehem 5 13. 13. uh uh the Tropicana
in Las Vegas May 20. May 28th that's a
big the Keswick theater May 18th uh
Chicago the company
Center what is that word I'll just take
your word for it it's all on your
website too so June 18th oh so why am I
doing this yeah I'm just following what
he's doing no you're smart but tomorrow
it is pre-sale for the Coney Island
Amphitheater 10 a.m but they can get all
that on
youtube.com deals on the tickets go to
Andrew Dice clay.com to look at this
tremendous tour schedule we'll be back
Monday night eight o'clock don't [__]
around we love you [__] Eleanor's
here I'll be in Jersey Uncle Vinny's
June 10th and 11th Uncle [__] Vinnies
then you'll see me oh no yes
I'll be in helium before you're gonna
work that together right yeah at least I
I did a podcast with a uh like a
licensed medical marijuana grower who
like has won awards and I just go to my
podcast life in neutral here all right
stay black have a great weekend I love
you guys thank you Andrew for coming on
thank you for having me do this thing
Lee
great
foreign